[Musique]
bonjour à tous sont nés le mardi 13
février et ce week-end donc j'étais au
play azur festival de nice qui s'est
très bien déroulé c'était très très
intéressant mais là je vais démarrer ce
bloc par quelque chose de très différent
qui n'a absolument rien à voir avec la
chaîne qui n'a rien à voir avec
l'archéologie
donc je vous préviens en fait je vais
c'est un témoignage quelque chose qui
sait à qui s'est passé à nice ce
week-end qui m'est arrivé et que je vais
donc vous expliquez vous expliquerai
après pourquoi je vous raconte cette
histoire et je vous invite ce que ça
n'intéresse pas ce genre de d'histoire a
tout simplement passés à aller au
prochain décor du blog
et voilà donc samedi soir après une
journée très riche de discussion de
conférences au festival on a décidé avec
des copains vidéaste rugari thater et
autres d'aller boire un verre sortir un
peu et profiter de la soirée tous
ensemble donc c'était c'était super bien
passé une très bonne soirée et on a donc
fini dans un bar boîte pas vraiment une
boîte de nuit c'est un dard qui ferme
très tard et où il ya une salle qui est
qui est faite pour danser qu'il y avait
plein de monde tout le monde dansait y
avait une ambiance géniale et donc on
est resté à peu près une heure et demie
dans cet endroit
mais voilà au bout de un quart d'heure
moi je lançais il ya un homme qui est
venu derrière moi qui a collé qui est
venu se frotter à moi qui a collé son
sexe contre mas fès et qui a mis sa main
sur mon sein
ça a pris ça c'est très rapide ans et a
pris trois secondes à se faire trois
secondes pour que je m'en rende compte
et ma réaction ça a été la suivante
c'est à dire que j'ai enlevé la main je
me suis retourné vers lui j'ai gueulé
créer l'effet inverse et
j'ai expliqué à la personne qui était à
côté de moi un pote ce qui s'était passé
qui est ce garçon là il n'en revenait
pas il m'a cru mais salah et aude et il
m'a dit viens décale un petit peu donc
c'est ce qu'on a fait on s'est décalé un
quart d'heure après je continue de
danser et je sens un doigt entre les
fesses un doigt qui vient me gratter la
raie des fesses
pareil je me retourne tout de suite pour
réagir et en fait je ne vois pas en fait
je vois plein de monde mais j'arrive pas
identifié qui a pu me faire ça il ya du
bruit je peux absolument pas réagir on
défend jeudi encore à aux mêmes potes
qui étaient accostés de à côté de moi
qui étais désolé donc on se décale
encore un peu un petit peu après il y à
une bande de personnes qui arrivent et
donc qu'ils essayent de se faufiler
entre les gens pour retrouver une place
dans la salle
et donc là moi je me pousse un petit peu
et au moment où il ya un homme qui passe
à côté de moi qui frôle mon épaule et au
moment où ils passent juste dans ma tête
et me chope la fesse dire qu'ils me
pince la fesse et c'est assez furtif un
set va très vite mais c'est pas c'est
pas un acte
c'est un acte volontaire ne sert
correctement la fesse et puis je me
retourne et pareil tu peux pas
identifier parce qu'il ya trop de monde
trop long trop de bruit les gens me
tourne le dos donc là je décide de
pas de partis en fait tourner ras-le-bol
ça me gâche un peu la alost la soirée et
au moment de partir il ya un dernier
homme qui vient me parler n'est pas
méchant mais il ya un peu lourdingue et
terre qui peut pas entendre que je suis
sur le point de partir et que je suis en
train de dire au revoir et il est vexé
en fait ça ça lui plaît pas et alors là
bas le seul truc que je trouve pour m'en
défaire c'est un gag que même un enfant
de 5 ans ne devrait pas un c'est le coup
de lui montrer ma ma bague à l'annulaire
et lui faire croire que c'est une
alliance et un autre copain à côté se
fait passer pour mon mari et l'a 4
partir de ce moment là que le mec baisse
les yeux et 120eme lâche enfin le de la
jambe droite de l'histoire les ce sont
des hommes qui nous gâcher la soirée je
dis bien des hommes et pas les hommes je
généralise pas qu'ils vont gâcher la
soirée qui m'ont embêter vraiment et ce
sont aussi des hommes qui nous quand
même permis de passer une bonne soirée
qui m'ont aidé dans ces moments là je
vais dire deux mecs de potes qui étaient
avec nous dans la bande vous n'avez
d'autre met donc à ce moment là c'était
deux mecs qui se reconnaîtront s'il
passe par là merci encore et qui m'ont
aidé et qui ont fait que j'ai quand même
un bon souvenir de cette soirée il s'est
quand même été un bon moment toute cette
soirée du samedi soir pourquoi je vous
raconte ça je vous raconte ça ici parce
que depuis samedi soir ça
ça cogite pas mal dans ma tête et il se
trouve que youtube
c'est le seul outil que j'ai à
disposition dans cette société qui soit
un outil facile d'accès et immédiat et
c'est là où j'ai envie de devoir avec
vous ce que vous en pensez c'est à dire
que vous laissez votre avis dans les
commentaires je demande pas qu'on qu'on
me plaigne quoi que ce soit parce que je
pense que j'ai six mois ont embêtés à ce
point en une heure et demie à quatre
reprises je n'ose même pas imaginer ce
que les autres nanas ont pu subir
la question c'est ça c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire concrètement pour
rendre ces lieux de de sociabilisation
sont des bars ou les boîtes de nuit
c'est c'est fait pour que les gens se
rencontrent et n'a à peu près tous le
même âge qu'on va danser dans ces lieux
là pour le même but c'est s'amuser
qu'est ce que le faire concrètement pour
que ce genre de situation n'arrive plus
on arrive quasiment plus alors moi j'ai
réfléchi depuis depuis ce week end
ça faisait longtemps que cela n'était
pas arrivé parce que ben je sais pas je
sors moins dans ces lieux là et je sais
pas j'avais l'impression qu'il ya 27 ans
était plus comme quand j'avais 18 ans je
pouvais peut-être avoir la paix à ce
niveau là et ben non alors je sais pas
jusqu'à quel âge ça ça dure ce genre de
de pratiquer ce cas je me suis dit ça ya
peut-être pas de limites
donc voila moi je réfléchis à qu'est ce
qu'on pourrait mettre en place pour que
les femmes comme les hommes parce que
les potes qui m'ont aidé à mon avis avec
autre chose j'avais envie de faire autre
chose que de faire écran et de penser à
moi et aux autres filles dans nos
demandes
moi je pense pas qu'on puisse changer la
mentalité des gens par contre je pense
qu'on peut toujours trouver des
solutions matérielles c'est à dire
réfléchir à l'espace dans lequel on se
trouve
et c'est de trouver d'un faire des
changements dans l'espace ajouté enlever
des choses là cet espace qui est
l'espace delà du bar de la boîte de nuit
c'est par essence est un lieu qui n'est
pas ne peut pas se mentir se protéger on
peut pas se faire entendre par la voix
parlée geste parce que la date de la
musique elle est forte
il ya beaucoup de monde et un truc qui
m'a qui m'étonne en fait dans ces lieux
là et c'est peut-être là une un truc à
réfléchir ensemble et peut-être qu'on
pourrait sa boîte une solution mais je
suis étonné que dans ces lieux il ya des
personnes qui sont chargés de la
sécurité
c'est ce qu'on appelle les videurs ils
assurent la sécurité à l'entrée et à la
sortie de ces lieux là bas pourquoi on
pourrait pas imaginer un videur dans la
salle danse c'est à dire l'endroit où ça
se passe réellement les gens sont eux
mêmes parce que c'est hyper hypocrite de
mettre des videurs qui à l'entrée d'un
lieu des gens en prennent sur eux il
faut jouer une bonne figure et après ça
part en live
donc pourquoi ne pas imaginer qu'ils ont
un videur toujours présents dans la
salle de danse à côté du bar alors
attention à ce qu'on dit ça c'est pas du
tout l'idée de de flicage
il n'est pas question de fliquer les
gens c'est une fois magique et une
figure de référence où on peut qu'on
peut aller chercher il ya ben voilà ça
fait une demi heure que je me fait
tripoter par des mecs
est ce que là dans les cinq minutes qui
suivent vous pouvez
regardez un peu la zone où je suis et si
vous voyez quelque chose de pas normal
vous virer la personne virer la personne
qui gêne
moi je pense que ce serait peut-être une
solution peut-être que ça existe
d'ailleurs et ça vous pouvez me le dire
en commentaire si vous connaissez des
des organisations de ce genre mais je
trouve ça trop dommage je trouve ça trop
dommage de ne pas pouvoir profiter
tranquillement en plus en n'étant pas
seule quoi moi j'étais bien accompagner
et je sais me défendre je sais dire ce
que je pense en plus je suis prudente
malheureusement que j'ai appris à faire
ça comme toutes les filles toutes les
femmes à à être vigilante à regarder qui
est autour de nous et ça me désole un
peu de me dire que c'est ça tous les
soirs dans toutes les boîtes du monde
entier c'est tout pour ce coup-ci retour
au format habituel mois elle c'est parti
d'un show
vaincus
nous sommes le lundi 26 février je suis
en voiture promis je vais pas vous
parler longtemps conduisant de risques
je vous emmène en tournage en trois
jours là je vais dans le var à côté
d'eux il ya les palmiers c'est un
endroit où que je connais bien que ce
que j'ai je me suis formée en plongée là
bas
et voilà c'est pour faire des images de
la maire des îles pour cros porquerolles
et puis ça permet de sortir un petit peu
de la zone de l'effort de sortir de chez
soi et c'est pas plus mal
allez c'est parti très jolie minaj butin
de plus de 6000 habitants s'y trouvent
maître de la paix
20 km ou non
mais bon
je n'ai 1000 euros les gars jouent leurs
jeunes et milan je viens d'arriver dans
le var donc je crois que pour le
tournage
c'est c'est foutu il neige voilà il ya
l'épaisseur de neige
j'étais parti pour filmer la mer quand
vous faisant croire que c'était l'été
donc c'est un échec du coup du coup j'ai
pris des billets pour faire toulon
florence demain matin et je vais tourner
à florence voilà voilà
on s'adapte on improvise c'est ça le
métier de youtube heures
[Musique]
salut je suis à florence je suis au pied
du mur
immense cathédrale avec la coupole vous
montrer mon train après et on fait
l'acropole pour aller tout en haut
allez
463 marché et moi j'ai le vertige partie
assez handicapant du coup j'ai envoyé la
personne à qui je suis là envie que
l'erreur pour me faire des images c'est
moi je peux je sais pas à quoi
m'attendre
on verra ainsi elle me dit que ça passe
j'irai bon bah là vient de m'envoyer un
texto en me disant ne montre fort voilà
justin rose
j'aurais été très très mal de granby
tant pis j'ai fait déjà le campanile ce
qui était pas mal mais ça s'est bien
passé
ce très beau mais du coup là je ne sens
pas la coupole c'est dommage c'est une
coupole qui est faite par brawn et les
skis un des plus grands architectes de
l'histoire
et c'est une prouesse architecturale en
fait parce que là deux bouts de
superposer et c'est assez unique
en fait nous sommes le 1er mars
toujours 1 florence je rentre ce soir
est donc là le programme qui neige y
nagent à florence donc j'espère que
j'aurai montrant sociaux le programme
aujourd'hui c'est musée du hard vélo qui
est un musée de la sculpture italienne
qui est très très riche
voir ça ensuite santa croce qui est une
église
très belle raquil et puis on verra on
verra si longtemps j'ai au musée du parc
vélo au musée de la sculpture donc comme
je vous ai dit avant c'est magnifique
maintenant si vous pouvez alain florence
aller à ce musée est une collection de
petits objets en tabletterie on se sont
d ivoire travail et les sculptures dans
l'eau c'est hyper france est merveilleux
il ya toute une collection de bijoux le
mauvais des bio aussi beau que rome mais
si tu partais l'eau
[Musique]
alors je ne suis pas à florence je ne
suis toujours pas en france
en fait j'ai quitté florence hier donc
aujourd'hui on est le vendredi 2 mars et
j'étais censé rentrer à lyon auprès des
gros gros gros problème de train tous
les trains en fait sont bloqués pour la
france ce qui est légèrement embêtant
parce qu'il faut vraiment que je sois à
lyon demain pour le lion science qui est
un festival organisé par le café des
sciences
il y à l'université lyon 1 et et voilà
il ya toujours la neige
donc en fait je suis en train de
comprendre pourquoi les tournages se
font surtout l'été que tournant en hiver
c'est très risqué en fait voilà
[Musique]